okay who's with me Who am I with me oh
you can also use rotation outlook on
these props yeah hey what's up hey
friend do you want to pay listen listen
what do you want to find props or do you
want to go drive a truck uh truck duh
bro come with me harms the horn no
shotguns out the side we have no time
for you walking beer no please drink it
[Laughter]
is this the kind of content that Disney
XP is looking for Wade doesn't exp yeah
DX P bro wait night wait and I got that
Disney Channel money now I'm just over
here hey it's over here something over
here moved I don't think that's right
hey you're stepping on it's moving right
now
yeah that's really
[Laughter]
we're gonna file the paperwork at least
it was a police accident I'm gonna tell
everybody that hay-bale had a knife or
something just making me watch this
right now I can't sir put the gun down
sir good start that's the kind of
light-hearted humor people come to our
channels to watch absolutely Wade what
kind of bit should we do here that was
[ __ ] edgy bro you have no idea yeah
you sure you want that round because
that had edge oh [ __ ] son hello fellow
atheist abortionist how are you doing
you ready to go kill some babies yeah
sorry killed enough babies this week
back into the swing of everything that
waits is like a bad metal song
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
baby baby baby baby thank you that's
what we used abortionist
have to do a new bid each round is up to
rule baby all the police wait just now
jack ignore them we're here to come here
I finally found a way to fulfill all of
our dreams of having a family and we
finally have our baby it over I'm sorry
the baby up it's our baby
Child Protective Services Protective
Services you guys are not trying to
protect the services I don't like this
bit okay problem with the way that
twitch is trying to get its partners
money then maybe you should tell them in
an email
or something less insane than blowing
everyone up I get it that's a bit pun I
get it yeah oh I just got it not cuz I
was bit just my a material you can only
have one or the other you have to pick
be funny your friends okay alright hey
guys I found that I thought of a new
joke okay where you are I'm crying okay
all right so you see me right here right
yeah okay right
hi I'm paint can I help you yeah okay
you got it
okay oh no it's so hard to control my
stools okay I like that one give another
what's that joke
corny you get you get corn in your
stools because it just digest properly
so many light to stand on jokes went
untold alright wait will present our
jokes to you yeah good job man thanks
man sick joke Sven all right you ready I
got I'll do mine first
alright alright you go ahead as the
proprietor of this event I request that
you perform on stage okay us okay all
right stage of our designation yes okay
all right we're gonna build you guys a
hey stage just Alka knee wait wait whoa
wait
one of you I need a beer bringing here
I'll shoot you come on this [ __ ] seat
oh okay they'll come on the shoe all
right
perform all right hi I'm pint can I help
you yeah the crowd a small bit on that
one
no it's clever I like that I live 50 on
that one okay what else you got
okay all right all right hey beer makes
it really funnier though don't touch me
anymore that makes me really unhappy
okay
colorful personality huh wait wait wait
wait we got to convene we think it's
okay all right
okay oh my god I fell out of my seat it
was so funny Wow Wow edge of his seat
edge of a seat everybody
yeah okay wait in on it okay drink me
[Laughter]
your bleach goods you are not bleed okay
can I go first sure sure you know I'm
good for punishment approaching so just
not secure okay yeah someone's walking
around I'm sorry I I was so ready okay
real quick do it again oh no no it's
it's over
that bets done it's not funny anymore
the joke was just punchline apparently I
meant I was trying to zoom in to look
all right Wade master of the universe
what's your hilarious idea yeah Wade I
get up there get on up go on you were so
eager to take control of the situation
what's what brilliance lies beneath the
dumb facade of your face for you
which one is you I'm visit me mark I'm
nice to meet you nice to meet you too hi
shakey shake shake shake so what is your
apology song I'm desperate to know don't
you please please don't shoot me babies
dom nom nom can I kill him please
I can we confer about this okay here
let's talk to mark mm what did you think
I thought he kind of just did another
song that he kind of did on the tour I
wasn't there so you're gonna have to
explain this to me something yay yay
alright fine which was by oh is that the
game now hey wait wait Jack I know how
to solve this I know how to solve this
no no
okay what's something to spread out I
was trying to make sure they didn't
catch on to my brilliant plan yeah that
plan was good bit good title this
episode already most offensive video
ever
yeah right sure of all time Wade has
never done anything more offensive than
these things this thing these things is
it a group of is it a single group of
things or is it multiple things that
he's done it's been Gaara is the plural
so listen you've already found my spot
Tech mark mark let's uh let's be friends
okay okay what's in it for me uh all of
the sharp prickly hey you want
let me have a roll in the hay I'll let
you have a roll into me that's not it
well first let me ask you a question
[Laughter]
guys I I just just barely made it what
can I do for you dude to me that piece
of garbage know what I'm in for
I asked you so politely not to shoot me
hey why can't you
oh no I'm sorry it was a good round of
bits good bits man
[Music]